have you ever had a workout session
where you felt like you were smashing it
and gave your best whereas on some
training days you feel like it just
wasn't your best effort although you
tried perhaps you might even experience
lightheadedness sluggishness or muscle
cramps during your workout there are
lots of different factors behind it but
consuming the right pre and post workout
meals can also play a huge role to your
workout performance they help you
perform your best and shape your results
let's take a deeper look into the
purpose of pre-workout versus
post-workout meals meal timing and what
you should be eating
let's first look at pre-workout meals
what is the rule of consuming a
pre-workout meal it's simple to fill
your activity and give your body what it
needs to perform at its peak
in order to do that your body needs two
things
carbs and protein
carbohydrates are the bodies quickest
and easiest source of fuel they're
especially important for high endurance
training and explosive training for
example heat workouts sprinting power
lifting and other fast-paced intense
sports and the harder and longer your
body is working the more carbs you'll
need to keep going there are two
different types of cups simple cups and
complex cups and they will have a
different effect on the body and your
performance simple cups or quick cups
come from simple sugars that are
digested rapidly providing you with
immediate energy examples include fruits
such as bananas apples dried fruits rice
cakes fruit juice honey sports gels and
other high sugar foods
complex cups or slow cups typically come
from starchy high fiber foods that are
slower to digest hence making them a
great source for long lasting energy
examples include whole grains oats beans
lentils broccoli potatoes and pasta
because complex cups take longer to
digest it should be consumed two to
three hours prior to your training for
instance it can be your lunch at 2 pm
and your training can be at 5 pm
simple cups on the other hand can be
consumed 30 to 60 minutes prior to
training and it can be a small snack as
a general rule of thumb do not eat
immediately before a workout not only
can it cause digestive discomfort but
this also creates competing demands on
the body if your stomach is trying to
digest food at the same time you're
pushing your muscle to perform
depending on the intensity and duration
of your training you may need to consume
both simple and complex cups
say you were planning for a long run and
a sprint session that can last up to two
hours then you need to fill your body
with enough complex and simple cups
however if your training session only
lasts between 45 to 60 minutes then a
small snack with simple cups is enough
to fill your performance in addition to
cups it is also important to consume a
little bit of protein before your
workout especially if you're doing
weight training when we do strength
training we create small tests in our
muscle fibers by consuming protein this
increases the number of amino acids in
the body and they help to repair those
micro tests maintain your lean mass
promote the building of muscle mass and
feel your strength training even more
efficiently
here are some great pre-workout snacks
that include a balance of simple cups
and protein
supplements can also be useful before
exercise it can help to enhance
performance improve strength reduce
fatigue and increase lean muscle mass
two of my favorite supplements which i
do consume pre-workout are caffeine and
bcaa caffeine can be found in coffee
tea energy drinks as well as pre-workout
supplements it has been shown to improve
performance increase strength and power
reduce fatigue and stimulate fat burning
personally i like to have a cup of black
coffee 30 to 60 minutes prior to
exercising to give me that extra boost
branched chain amino acids or bcaas are
a group of three essential amino acids
leucine isoleucine and valine which
can't be produced by the body and must
be consumed from food it is one of the
most common sports supplements consumed
pre and also during exercising to boost
muscle growth and enhance exercise
performance and they may also help with
weight loss and reduce muscle soreness
after exercising
now that you know what to eat before
your training for you to maximize your
performance
what you consume after your training is
equally if not even more important the
main purpose of a post-workout meal is
to supply your body with everything it
needs to rehydrate repair replenish
refill recover and keep improving your
future performance once again
your body needs both carbs and protein
however the emphasis for post-workout is
on protein
eating a high protein meal after
exercise helps your body to minimize
muscle protein breakdown
stimulate protein synthesis which leads
to increase in muscle tissue
replenish muscle glycogen reduce muscle
soreness reduce cortisol also known as
stress hormone levels
so how soon should you consume your post
workout meal the simple answer is as
soon as possible within the first 60
minutes after your workout or even
better within the first 30 minutes why
is the timing of your post-workout meal
so crucial
if your body has exhausted all its
reserves during the workout it will
result to breaking down muscle in order
to feel itself and we want to avoid that
because it is not easy to build muscle
mass i'm sure we have seen fitness
people consuming a protein shake
immediately after their training session
that's because a protein shake is a
super convenient and fast post-workout
recovery drink that has a good balance
of both protein and cups and sometimes
you may find that your appetite is
suppressed following a tough workout
hence making liquid nutrition a more
appealing option
some of you may ask is it enough just to
consume protein shake do i still need to
consume a real meal the answer is yes
remember that protein shake is a
supplement and the purpose is to
supplement your diet it should not be
replacing real whole foods
you have to still consume a real meal
with a balance of protein starchy cups
and healthy fats within one to two hours
after your workout your body tolerates
and processes carbohydrates most
efficiently in the three hour window
post workout so this is your best window
to eat your studio cups eating cups
after exercise will replenish your
glycogen stores which you have used up
during your workout and it will also
improve your ability to bounce back and
come back stronger for your next workout
here's a general guideline of what your
post-workout meal should contain for
protein 0.25 grams per pound of your
target body weight and for cubs 0.25 to
0.05 grams per pound of your target body
weight remember this is just a guideline
if you were to perform more intense
weight training session that lasts up to
90 minutes or if your goal is to build
more lean muscles then you may require
more protein in your diet
another common question is
is it a must to consume protein shakes
post-workout the answer is no
if you're able to consume a proper real
meal within 30 to 45 minutes after
you've finished training then it is not
necessary to consume protein shakes
protein shakes act as a supplement which
is super convenient and easily
accessible
here are some examples of post workout
meals
the bottom line is that you need both
calves and protein pre and post workout
for sustained energy improved
performance and better muscle recovery
there isn't a one-size-fits-all solution
when it comes down to having the right
meal and timing you have to keep trying
different meals and timing and see which
fits your body and the type of activity
you do for example i perform better when
i consume a small snack 30 minutes
before training whereas some of you
might find that you need at least an
hour window of eating prior to
exercising it is also important to
remember that your pre and post workout
snacks should be included as part of
your total daily calorie intake and last
but not least staying hydrated and
drinking sufficient water before
during and after all your workouts is
one of the most important steps you can
take to properly fill your body and
achieve the results you're looking for
it's important to minimize dehydration
which can cause low energy and muscle
cramps or spasms
if you have any other questions in
regards to pre and post workout
nutrition or any other training
questions do let me know in the comments
below if you enjoyed this video if you
find this video to be useful then give
this video a thumbs up share this video
on with your friends and encourage them
to stay active and don't forget to also
subscribe to my youtube channel and i
will see you in my next video
all the best